batman fans have clocked in their second
and third views of the batman by now
wondering what details they're spotting
that you didn't keep watching to find
out
robert pattinson's bat suit is one of
the most functional looking to date but
it's partially inspired by a much older
design modern filmmakers know that
batman needs to be decked out in armor
to deflect bullets he isn't superman
after all but he still needs to look
like batman perhaps the most
recognizable aspect of batman's attire
is his cow
unlike the ones worn by christian bale
and ben affleck robert pattinson's cowl
isn't one seamless mold instead it's
multiple pieces stitched together this
reflects the homemade nature of his
outfit this is an early years batman
let's not forget but there's more to it
than that when you take a closer look at
the cowl seen in the batman you'll
notice that the nose piece is flat and
stitched onto the headwear if it looks
oddly familiar that's because adam
west's caped crusader wore a similar cow
matt reeves confirmed in a q a via
insider that the new cow was inspired by
the one worn by west in the classic 60s
tv show
every batman story needs a solid villain
and the batman has exactly that the
riddler bludgeons his way through
gotham's corrupt leadership leaving a
trail of clues for batman to decipher on
the surface the riddler is a madman
exacting brutal revenge upon those
sucking the life out of gotham in
reality however he's simply emulating
the dark knight the riddler even states
that batman inspired him a closer
inspection of the riddler's crusade
reveals just how similar he and batman
are for starters they both hide behind
masks which according to the riddler
allows them to be their true selves both
are orphans with personas born from
tragedy a major plot point in the film
they both hold a deep hatred of the
corrupt batman brutalizes his enemies
while the riddler violently murders them
whether bruce wayne likes it or not he
and the riddler are similar both men are
on a quest for vengeance a word that
holds significant meaning for the dark
knight i'm vengeance
it's only when one of the riddler's
followers also claims to be vengeance
that batman realizes he must elevate his
mission to one of hope
batman always has a few allies around
despite his lone wolf act one of the
most important among them is alfred who
has always been by the caped crusaders
side
the version of the loyal butler scene in
the batman played by andy serkis appears
to be more of a family bodyguard at one
point alfred tells bruce that it was his
duty to protect thomas and martha and
states at another point that he taught
bruce how to fight
batman's combat prowess is there for all
to see so it's likely that alfred is a
skilled fighter himself it's not an idea
without precedent the batman earth 1
comic features a version of alfred that
trained bruce in all that he knows as he
was a former operative in the sas
you needed a father
and all you had was me
at the beginning of the film a minor
detail concerning alfred's face may go
unnoticed initially viewers who examine
his left eyebrow will see that he has a
scar or abrasion of some sort long
before he takes the brunt of the
riddler's bomb in wayne tower the scar
could be from his past or perhaps alfred
has assisted batman in the field just as
he did in batman earth 1. it's a mystery
for now but it's definitely a visual
clue that indicates a violent history
the batman establishes that carmine
falcone had a history with thomas wayne
in the film falcone recalls bruce's
physician father operating on him in the
wayne household saying that he saw a
young bruce looking down on the scene
from the staircase the mobster indicates
that he and thomas were close but bruce
isn't having any of it the younger wayne
says that all it means is that his dad
took the hippocratic oath later batman
apprehends falcone and brings him out
into the open where he gets shot by the
riddler the dark knight is looking down
at the gangster as he draws his final
breath and falcon appears to realize
something just before he dies one could
argue that he's simply in shock having
been shot but falcone has a distinct
look of surprise on his face as he gazes
up at the dark knight could it be that
he just realized that bruce wayne is the
batman it would seem to bring the story
that falcone told bruce earlier in the
film full circle if true it's a subtle
but poetic detail that gives some extra
weight to the villain's death
jim carrey portrayed a far more
eccentric version of the riddler in joel
schumacher's batman forever a film that
couldn't be more different from the
batman in terms of approach while batman
forever is generally considered one of
the less memorable batman movies many
critics praised carrie's performance
with his over-the-top antics suiting the
style of the movie it appears as though
matt reeves and the costume designers
for the batman decided to honor carrie's
take on the riddler by giving paul
dono's version of the character the same
glasses the clear framed spectacles he's
seen in look almost identical to those
briefly worn by carrie's edward enigma
before he switches to his villainous
contact lenses it's a subtle but clear
nod to the character's history and you
may not be able to look at paul dyno's
version of the riddler the same way
again as a result
not how this was supposed to go
batman has undergone a transformation by
the time the film comes to a close in
the beginning bruce's mission is in
desperate need of some better pr when
the innocent people of gotham are afraid
of the caped crusader that's a bit of a
red flag at first citizens loved
batman's brutal quest for vengeance but
much like the vigilante himself they
soon realized that a hero needs more
than just anger to do good in the world
the early moments of the batman show a
soul who is just as crushed and defeated
as those attempting to survive in the
worst parts of the city bruce is angry
his hatred of the criminal element is on
full bone crunching display as he
viciously pummels bad guys into the
ground he's a creature of the night who
only feels comfortable in the shadows
after all bruce is seen walking around
in doors during daylight hours with
sunglasses on he's either sensitive to
the light from long nights in the dark
or he and the light just don't mix
in the third act however bruce begins to
embrace a new purpose providing hope to
the people of gotham he leads the
humanitarian efforts as the city reacts
to the flooding caused by the riddler
gone are the rage-filled days of
vengeance this is a new batman who isn't
afraid to be out during the day a
symbolic echo of the character's growth
the riddler goes after the wayne family
hard when he's airing gotham's dirty
laundry he alleges that thomas wayne had
a journalist murdered in cold blood the
reason the journalist had information
about martha wayne's psychiatric
struggles and he threatened to go public
with it during thomas wayne's mayoral
campaign
alfred clears up the messy story for
bruce explaining that thomas didn't care
about the campaign only about the harm
the information would do to his wife he
did ask falcone for help dissuading the
reporter from publishing but only as a
last resort thomas went through the
proper channels at first even sending a
cease and desist letter a portion of
that letter is shown up close in one
scene where it's revealed that it was
sent from the miller and moore law firm
comic book fans will immediately
recognize those names as references to
frank miller and alan moore who wrote
the dark knight returns and the killing
joke respectively both are prolific
comic book writers who have made
significant contributions to the world
of batman over the years and the letter
serves as a nice nod to their legacies
the riddler's plot to destroy gotham's
sea wall and flood the city was in the
works for quite some time it would seem
late in the film we learned that he's
been planning a series of devastating
explosions with other radicals online
however one long since past event set
the stage for the seawall being an
exploitable tool for the riddler it
turns out that the funding provided by
the renewal project was supposed to go
towards the upkeep of the seawall
confirmed in a blink and you'll miss it
moment in an image of newspaper
clippings that flashes up on the screen
one headline is noteworthy seawall
construction stalled
this headline indicates that seawall
safety was put on the back burner when
the funding mysteriously vanished it
left the wall vulnerable and the riddler
knew it the greed of those in power left
the city in a dangerous position which
the villain was able to exploit
the batman might paint a bleak portrait
of a city drowning in its own filth but
there are still a few moments of levity
in there the riddler cracks a rather
morbid joke near the start of the film
attaching the mayor's actual thumb to a
thumb drive
jim gordon is also quick to hit those
sarcastic notes offering viewers the odd
chuckle
oh this guy's hilarious
after batman uses the batmobile to flip
penguin's car he and gordon begin to
interrogate the crooked club owner they
believe that he's the one who ratted on
the moroni crime family long-time rivals
of the falcone family of course the
penguin insists that he isn't the rat
and is even disgusted by the suggestion
he also unintentionally gives batman a
new lead when batman and gordon exit the
scene they leave penguin standing there
with his hands and legs tied it's one of
the funniest moments in the movie the
penguin waddles like an actual penguin
as he yells at the departing good guys a
choice that must have been made with the
animal in mind early in the batman bruce
wayne discusses his bleak outlook for
gotham amongst a montage of thugs
committing crimes all over the city one
of these crooks is robbing a convenience
store while wearing a green mask that
looks like a misshapen jack-o-lantern
this mask comes across as
inconsequential the first time you watch
the movie it's halloween night after all
and the robber wants to hide his face
for obvious reasons we come to realize
that this is no store-bought halloween
mask however
the mask actually resembles a drop the
fictional drug that is plaguing gotham
they are administered through the eyes
and they are apparently highly addictive
the mask resembles an image of a drop
scene on an anti-drug billboard but the
psa doesn't appear to be helping very
much
the riddler is an enigmatic killer
shrouded in mystery once batman begins
following the trail of clues and carnage
he learns more about the villain and
what he's really after while the riddler
clearly has a motive in mind his style
bears resemblance to the fictional
serial killer that made a big splash in
1978's halloween the opening moments of
the batman were given a voyeuristic view
through the riddler's eyes we hear
steady breathing from behind his mask
much like the young michael myers the
riddler then stalks the mayor waiting in
the shadows once the moment is right he
emerges and brutally murders his victim
in true michael myers fashion later in
the film another famous halloween scene
is replicated when d.a gil calson
becomes the riddler's next victim the
unsuspecting law man gets into his car
but he's not alone the riddler is
waiting in the back seat and by the time
he notices it's too late
while he doesn't kill coulson then and
there it's a parallel to any bracket's
death in the slasher classic
matt reeves has indeed confirmed that he
took cues from several 70s films with
the french connection chinatown and taxi
driver all providing inspiration in
different ways check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]